he's going to be thrilled at but
certainly thrilled to
win a game jeffrey it's been a long and
hard tournament
yeah definitely um
yeah i was thinking about it on the rest
of yesterday and i
think in i mean when i come here to play
in the u.s championship i've always
struggled uh actually
i think maybe the first year was my best
result and i only scored 50 percent but
otherwise
i mean after that i
was uh always in in the minus so
and then here yeah i came and i was
hoping okay maybe this is the year that
i can turn things around but
i dropped three in a row very very early
so
yeah it's just been a battle uh uphill
climb after that
definitely difficult tournament for you
this one it looked like all right the
game seems a bit balanced everybody's
king is safe it's about this pawn is
blockaded and then all of a sudden you
decided g5 let's go
yeah i thought g5 was
maybe my best uh practical try uh but
can we go a little bit uh earlier
because i wanted to mention some
interesting moments
so yeah basically let's even even uh
yeah keep going back uh all the way
when i before i played knight before
i think
so
yeah right here uh yeah before
and originally i was thinking bishop
okay 95 and i thought i could go
something simple like bishop eight at
first
but then i think
after queenie two
let's say rook c8
i think he just wanted to go like bishop
d2 and
at first i was very optimistic about my
position with the bishop on a7 but
um i'm really not sure how to proceed
from here because he's just gonna have
c4 maybe next
so that's why i decided to kind of force
the action with knight b4
and i think if queen e2
uh bishop b5
c4
here i have two options i can go bishop
a back and say that maybe i provoked c4
and i have this b4 square for the night
i'm not sure
uh what the valuation is but there's
also a very interesting move knight d3
after c4
and now he has two options you can go cb
or knight d3 um let's say knight d3
now i think i take with the queen
actually whoa
yeah uh and then yeah it gets very messy
uh he has
two moves either queen do you want her
knight uh knight dc5 i think
it was
knight d yeah knight dc5 okay
and the thing is uh if i let's say i go
queen c5
knight c5 bish b2
i have a feeling if he takes on b7 i
take on f1 and i'm better but he can
take on e6 here
instead
and for sure i'm now i'm probably worse
so yeah i don't think this works but uh
instead of queen spot i have queen d5
wow
crazy crazy
crazy lion
and then the thing is yeah if queen e5 i
think i
oh yeah i think after bishop one you
just go king f1 and
maybe there's nothing there
although i mean it's still
very yeah i don't know what's going on
but probably i would have i would have
gone bishop e8 because also he could uh
i think cb5 was also unclear here
like cb5 bishop f2
uh he can go to either square but let's
say king g2 maybe
knight e1 king f2 knight c2
um
yeah i don't know maybe his rook a four
i'm done in queenie five but yeah i i
have no idea yeah
yeah i'd probably go bishop to be honest
nice yeah it's just
crazy but then i think he started out
playing me a little bit uh in the game
so queen b1 knight c6 takes
yeah this
i think it was i didn't see anything
better for me but
yeah if you just keep going i think he
started to
to outplay me
like rookie three yeah and age 24.
and then yeah i we get to this moment
after um
i thought i was actually in trouble
because so after rookie two
knight g5 knight c5
okay yeah stop here so
i was very worried about king h1 for a
second
after knight f3 yeah because
the point is rook d2 knight e4
and i thought i'm just losing an
exchange
um
it looks
but here yeah luckily i have queen
yeah oh
this was very important and now i think
it's a complete turnaround
so yeah i was lucky to have this so he
has to take on b7
or sorry he has taken f3 and b7
and then there's another trick if i i
want to go knight b4 at first after 97.
yes but now he's got uh queen e4 sorry
knight b4 knight yeah
sorry he's got queen e4 rook do you want
king h2 and surprisingly i'm just lost i
think
wow
that's an easy tactic to fall for yeah
so i had to go the other way with knight
d4
but now i think it's just equal
uh takes takes
i think he did very well by doing rook
d2 because if he goes rook d1
i think
uh i think the point was queen b5 maybe
and
if i can win the apon then it's very
pleasant for me but
yeah rook d2 was
was precise
okay
and now yeah i was thinking for a long
time
i think i i didn't choose a very good
way i played because i wanted to go rook
d5
and threaten e5 originally but
i think he was rook d3 here so he has
if e5 would be three and otherwise i'm
not sure
how to continue
so that's i went queen d5 but after b4
e5
i think i was surprised why you didn't
go rook 81 here
because if anything
he's definitely not at risk i think i
have to take on d4
three times and i i don't think i don't
believe he's at any risk here but it
should be a draw i would say
yeah queen somewhere yeah it should be a
draw i think but if anyone's trying it's
white yeah it feels so right
so i think maybe he missed my response
slightly like after queen you threw
queen b7 i think was a good response
um
queen
yeah
to gain a tempo i see and then yeah now
okay finally we come to this moment that
maurice mentioned with uh g5
and i was very surprised when he took
because i thought he could just go h5
exactly i would keep the greens again
yeah and
i mean my point was that maybe in some
rook end games this pawn can become a
target but it's really not very relevant
um i'd probably go queen b5
i wasn't sure but yeah maybe queen b5
and yeah the game goes on but it should
be about equal but yeah i think when he
took he missed this trick rookie
i think rook gate was very lethal
so there's a nice line of ba six rookie
one
whoops uh
takes queen b3
rookie eight
okay there might be other ways to win
but let's say rookie king g7 a7
rook a6
uh promote and then queen b1 is a strong
check
oh nasty
yeah so if you go to stage 2 i have rook
h6 of king 2 i take queen e4
you know king h2 rook h6 will be made
king g2
rook takes rook takes and you pick up
the rook so yeah that's why
the other line i was interested about
was he can try b6
uh here okay
and then i was going rook h6 f3 rookie
three
queen d1 rook f3 i mean it looks huge
but it's i wasn't 100 because
you know pawn on b6 maybe if he doesn't
get mated
but i think so
maybe he has to richie too uh take on g3
queen e2
and i was happy to find rook gh3 there
might be other moves but i like rook gh3
and if rooks have king of fate and if
queen eight king aged seven so i think
it should be just winning uh sorry
repeat queenie king h7 yeah so he's just
out of checks i see so yeah this should
be winning uh so that's why he had to go
queen d1
and sorry jeffrey we just have a traffic
jam right behind you as a lot of players
are
searching for getting ready for
interviews as well
we just have one question we just got to
ask you though uh in the game what
happened was when did you see queen h8
that was the money move for us
well actually i was i was very upset
with myself uh about playing a b5 i feel
like i should have gone rook h6 right
away
um because here i think rook b4 actually
he's still in the game maybe a b5 rook
b4
ah i thought he maybe i led him back in
the game
we didn't we missed that moment
yeah because okay it's complex i i won't
show everything but yeah so this which
yeah but yeah yeah yeah early
yeah i know here yeah yeah quniche was
always i mean i always had ideas of you
know
having this uh battery on the hvac
very nice and then you went on
for a clean win well congratulations on
your victory uh jeffrey
thanks
keep it up keep it i'll see you tomorrow